as humans we
want to connect with other people we
want to be appreciated and liked that
that is universal but at the end of the
day you can't care more about what
people think of you than you think of
yourself and that needs to become the
mantra that you build into your life in
fact the theme of today's episode i'm
going to say is taking control of your
life and these first two statements are
all about that are these first two
questions you can't control your own
life you can't control your own mind if
you allow yourself to care more about
what other people think of you than you
think of yourself so that needs to be
the compass by which you steer now that
doesn't mean that it isn't going to suck
when people disapprove of you they say
they don't like what you're doing man
that's hard i'm telling you right now
that is still hard for me and this is
something that i put a lot of energy
into but at the end of the day even when
it stings even when it hurts i know i
need to be true to myself